a gente bloqueia uma substância
essencial para tentar matar o tumor. O
tumor dá um jeito, continua crescendo,
mas o paciente fica cada vez mais fraco,
com intestino ferrado, imunidade baixa e
músculos derretendo. Então isso não é
tratamento, isso é quase uma sabotagem.
E tem mais uma coisa que a medicina
convencional insiste em ignorar. Nem
todo mundo é viciado em glutamina.
Desculpa, nem todo mundo não. Nem todo o
tumor é viciado em glutamina. Da mesma
forma, tem tumor que usa, tem tumor que
nem liga tanto assim, mas os remédios
que bloqueiam glutamina não fazem
extinção, eles bloqueiam para todo mundo
de forma indiscriminada. Então é como
usar bomba atômica para matar mosquito.
Funciona, talvez,
mas será que vale a pena? Até o momento
não parece valer a pena. M.